these three numbers belong to the
international numbering system and these
two belong to the indian numbering
system now let us look at a few
interesting examples
how will we write these numbers in the
indian and the international numbering
systems the first number is 1000 in both
the systems the second number in the
indian numbering system would be 1 lakh
and 100 000 in the international
numbering system
similarly the third number will be 5
lakhs and in the international numbering
system it will be 500 000 or half a
million you could say the fourth number
in the indian system will be 10 lakhs
and in the international numbering
system it will be 1 million similarly
the fifth number will be 75 lakhs or 7.5
million and the sixth number in the
indian numbering system will be 1 crore
and in the international numbering
system it will be 10 million
before taking your leave here's a
question for you all how will you write
this number in the indian numbering
system and the international numbering
system leave your answers in the
comments section